our solution for parsing the Atlas
definition is pretty straightforward
first we're given Atlas JSON data that's
been loaded from an xhr request the
first step that we need to do is
actually go through and call json.parse
on that this will turn the text JSON
data into an actual JavaScript object
with members and values that we can
iterate over we use this to effect here
the parse the object has a frames
dictionary that will actually iterate
over to load all of our sprites we'd
like to fetch each key inside of our
dictionary and then fetch the Associated
sprite object that comes with it
from here we now have the sprite name
and effectively the sprite values the
next step we take here is to actually
define the center of the image so we
actually multiply the width and the
height times 0.5 which would give us the
half width and half height now we store
this value in a CX and CY is a negative
offset the reason for this is it will
use the CX and CY values a little later
on during rendering to transform our
object into proper space we store them
as negatives here so that we don't have
to do the mathematics later on when
we're drawing the image once we've got
this data we go ahead forward and call
the DEF sprite function passing in the
image name as a key and then the frame X
frame Y width height and center data
that you've already seen before